selon mes informations dana et que l'on
a reçue et warda ou travailler ensemble
dans le passé sur de nombreuses
pratiques de nombreuses affaires et tout
ça est jugée troubles opaque contestable
par l'institut des arts divinatoires qui
fait office de référence en france des
gens attaqués par des voyantes
donc pour moi warda a participé avec
damas et à des opérations que je
qualifierais de belliqueux tueuse ou de
complexes et par rapport à carla selon
mes informations il ya eu effectivement
des menaces il ya eu des pressions et
selon les informations c'est ce que j'ai
dit warda aurait aidé damas et a menacé
et peut-être enquête le démontrera à
extorquer des fonds à carling alors
justement warda est avec nous bonsoir
warda bonsoir bonsoir tout le monde
merci d'être avec nous howard a donc
warda ce soit est ce que pour vous car
là est victime d'une escroquerie
non attendez qu'est ce qu'il a dit
gilles merguez là tu as des preuves
comment je leur laisse auparavant eu
alors à des preuves je ramène des
preuves là tu en train d'accuser c'est
de la diffamation ce que vous êtes en
train de dire à la barre d'où vous savez
les preuves alors je ne savais pas que
je la connais sopassure acquitté car il
va vous répondre alors y'a des choses
sur le fait que vous ayez train sur le
fait que vous ayez travaillé avec dana
et dans le passé
vous reconnaissez donc les liens alors
ward a donc dana alors gilles verdez
alors ça c'est la première chose que
vous mais elle dit qu'elle n'a rien à
voir avec l'affairé ward a donc alors
des bons d'achat elles ont des liens du
passé et selon m
normal quand je connais bien oui elles
peuvent se reconnaître qu'elle était
enceinte dans la sphère madame warda
madame wada a demandé madame varda avez
vous avez vous pour dit avec votre
client dana et des pressions des menaces
ou 10 sur des candidats de télé-réalité
avez vous pratiqué contre des candidats
de télé réalité s'est fondée s'il vous
plaît si vous voulez bien
non mais ward a pas du tout je vous pose
la question alors qu'à la braderie
version on aimerait avoir votre version
comme ça alors allez-y dite noire elle
et bellewaerde en tout cas très belle
vrai alors ward a dit nous votre version
sais que j'ai les crapauds les
informations cela c'est très très très
rare et bien c'est important warda merci
à leurs idées pour merguez alors non
mais dont vous sortez les informations
merkel institut des arts divinatoires
sur le passé et je peux passer raconte
ludivine à toi je travaille
madame ward a travaillé vous vous ne
répondez pas travailler vous s'il vous
plaît mal à voir da avec notamment
marocains contre des candidats de télé
réalité pouvait me répondre je te perds
le match et pas quoi faire oui moi les
chats ou les marocains d'avoir d'avoir
battu donc vous n'avez rien à voir avec
cette affaire n'ont rien vous n'avez pas
besoin de vous déplacer vous travailler
à distance et vous avez dit ce n'est pas
moi qui vais à eux c'est eux qui
viennent à moi donc répondez moi
avez vous pratiqué de la voyance de la
sorcellerie à l'encontre ou en faveur de
candidats de télé réalité
[Musique]
qu'avez-vous fait comme sorcellerie a
longtemps s'il vous plaît de certains
marseillais qu'avez-vous fait madame
s'il vous plaît madame warda c'était pas
la question ça c'était pas la réponse à
la question là je vous pose la question
là
les clients attendent et pour répondre à
votre question oui font appel à moi j'ai
pas fait du travail à l'encontre des
marseillais avec la danone
d'ailleurs j'ai pas toi j mag est
d'accord la dame se savait malade à
calmer bouffer savais où je sais pas
vous mais si tu y accrocher des crapauds
wardak est ce que vous avez fait des
travaux je fais mon travail mais
quelques raccords et madame haidar
hameedi nous avons de quoi il viendra
mais attendez laissez moi parler ça rien
à voir avec la nano moi ça rien à voir
d'accord ça rien à voir me demander de
faire mes cheveux sur carla et j'allais
mélangez pas tout mais ne trouve pas ma
cliente et avec elle le problème de
carla il est le père quelle arnaque et
gilbert gress d'accord et là vous étiez
en train de me paraît deux fois lille m
chip à quoi travaille pas enfreint soit
jeux java qui juste de voir des voyages
suis pas quoi là ward a donc pour vous
donc notre vote version c'est que dany
vous a demandé à vous de faire des
travaux pour elle
voilà c'est ça pourrait se regarde là et
des clients est giros luzech et pas de
la sous traitance
ben vous avez refusé tout à fait donc
vous n'avez rien à voir dans cette
affaire de carla non amis j'alerte échos
qui a eu le problème de carrelage est
alerté madame magali berda j'ai dit
d'accord
madame magali d'un lac et donc c'est
magali berda qui qui est un peu l'agent
de cas l'an passé elle est dans son
agent soit là pour faire du placement de
produit c'est ça vous l'avez dit quoi
magali berda et ben j'avais pas sans
numéro direct j'ai transmis un message
auquel était au courant quand elle est
au courant de l'histoire qui avait une
bombe qu'elle est sortie
bon hélas y avait ici à la fin si
familière elle a pris part de mon
message que dix jours après j'ai dit
attention il ya une vidéo qui va sortir
c'est pas novateur c'est danone après la
garde à vue qui va sortir cette vidéo ça
s'est passé c'est d'allonnes qui
l'envoyaient cette vidéo etc m'a guéri
donc c'est danone 1 ça n'a rien à voir
avec d'annette tulio plaît pourquoi
pourquoi vous n'avez pas contacter
directement les forces de l'ordre la
police
mais moi je suis j'étais à dubaï respect
mais ward à pau pour pour résumer donc
parce que ce soir gilles verdez avez dit
que vous étiez dans la sphère donc vous
n'êtes pas du tout dans affaires vous
danaé vous avez demandé de faire des
travaux apparemment c'est votre version
et vous vous lavez vous avez refusé et
donc votre égard si vous postez vous le
savez très bien
voilà donc donc donc vous n'avez rien à
voir avec la sphère de carla non juste
la ferme de carla j'ai alerté dans la m
a demandé je les envoyais et les audio
elle m'a demandé de faire des travaux
sur carla ont bloqué la procédure je ne
veux pas je ne peux pas travailler pour
cette femme après moi c'est pas moi
bonjour madame warda moi je trouve très
belle
on s'adore madame ward agissent très
belle et je vous adore pas projet
d'accord parce que vous avez les impôts
c'est une question sur instagram
on entend des audio entre vous et dana
et pourtant vous avez l'air de pas
l'aimer ce soir mais vous aviez l'air de
bienvenue ont tendance à tous les
clients je suis sympa je parle à tout le
monde mais sa sorcière aussi je
comprends pas pardon c'est c'est une
cliente à van damme a eu alors que c'est
une sorcière
le bill la compa la contacter phase des
travaux tout adressé pas faire c'est ça
c'est ça ward a ri voilà ce qu'on met
jamais de travaux pour elle d'accord
d'accord donc warda quel est votre
conclusion alors ce soit que vous avez à
dire alors bon tout le monde c'est vrai
c'est mitigé tout le monde dit c'est
faux ils sont pour la team mashaal qui
ne mâche un accord ce bilan mais je vais
vous dire la vérité il ya réellement du
racket ya réellement tout raté il n'y a
pas de cas là c'est ça c'est pour ça que
chez nrj ya les gens du peuple qui a des
clients pouvaient à combien de reprises
elle a dit si tu me payes pas telle
somme je vais montrer à tomber que tu
m'a ramené sa photo tous les leurs un
travail parce qu'elle prend tous les
coordonnées elle pose la question ils
travaillent ou qui ce qu'il fait elle
fait du chantage
c'est tout le temps c'est pas eu c'est
pas deux c'est plusieurs gars là bon ça
a été une grosse heure
les autres et des 25000 euros la saison
c'est non c'est non
il y a plusieurs ils vivent à plusieurs
les animaux les rechercher to save a
plusieurs dans cette maison et ses
mafias sénat pierre racketteurs d'accord
parce que elle elle travaille avec ces
influenceurs donc forcément ils sont
amis son ami et ça quand ils vont partir
ils savent leur maison ils s'attaquent
aux et les cambriolages et pèse mes mots
ça vient de son équipe de son équipe à
tout ça de son équipe
très bien merci ouargla merci warda pour
votre témoignage merci ward à vous
internautes atteint des trucs à dire à
jean bernège lui l'arrêt taxquet
là il arrive existence de merde est lui
quelque chose à me dire voilà il est
très gentil gilles verdez savez je
rappelle que les propos de royal en gach
cas elle bien dans sa vie c'est sa
version d'été comme on a vu les trois
versions du mois on a trois versions
gilles madame warda moi j'aimerais bien
que notre foi si vous voulez
réfléchissez vous nous disiez exactement
parce que vous c'est que vous savez tout
tout ce qui se passe en matière de
sorcellerie à l'intérieur de la télé
réalité vous pouvez passer outre le fait
du secret professionnel
vous le savez très bien en plus y'a une
enquête de police donc j'aimerais que
vous nous disiez tout est ce que vous
êtes capable de nous dire tout alors est
ce que vous êtes capables de rétablir la
vérité ce que vous avez colporté ces
faux sur moi je parle alors gilles à ça
me paraît un deal acceptable madame
franchement je vais vérifier franchement
je vais vérifier auprès de mes sources
c'est le sbbl warda mais alors vérifier
auprès de mes sources vous nous direz
toute la vérité sur la sorcellerie dans
la télé réalité
oui à nous le dira tout cas d'avoir été
là bercy warda